[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at our respective tables
of adequate and varied lighting we're
gonna be talking about therapy
specifically a discussion that we
started to have just on our own that we
were like hey that would be a good ear
ear biscuit yeah I think I mentioned on
this show when I decided to start to go
back to therapy some months back and
having started to go to therapy for the
first time I'm I now find myself
processing a lot about beginning that
process and there's lots of interesting
questions that pop into my mind some of
which I think or I might need to take to
therapy honestly because I don't know if
they're the right questions I think the
questions that I'm asking and the way
that I am approaching therapy and
experiencing it as I start reveals more
about me than it does about therapy but
I kind of want to talk through that a
little bit more because you've been
going to therapy for a while now not two
years yet right maybe toked over two
years over two years so for me I've done
I'm Way ahead I guess I shouldn't that
should have still never catch up it's
less than ten sessions that I've done so
I'm interested to hear your take on it
and also share with you listening about
my experience whether you've ever been
to therapy or you've never been to
therapy if you're thinking about going
maybe some of this discussion can be
helpful for you or encouraging or and I
don't know what it will be but I just
feel like I'd like to talk about it and
explore this because
there's a lot there yeah you're just
scratching the surface and this excited
for it and this is a lot cheaper this is
a lot cheaper I'm gonna be honest we're
actually making money doing this in
order to pay for therapy
the couple of as they say on some other
podcasts housekeeping issues okay I love
housekeeping I do want to acknowledge
the fact that I realized that when I say
that we need to do a podcast episode
about something and I say or I say we've
got to record I say we've got to record
any or biscuit and I use the singular
but you always say we've got to record
in ear biscuits and I just kind of feel
like we need to we need to get to the
bottom of that here's the presence
it's the hashtag man because it's like I
think as you know I think it turns the
hashtags and what is the hashtag for
this show is it
hashtag ear biscuit no it's hashtag ear
biscuits that's also the name of the
show so we're going to record another
ear biscuits episode that doesn't and I
don't think I don't think I'm stepping
on their hashtag by saying in your
biscuit no I that one episode of your
biscuits is an ear biscuit exactly but
what I'm saying is not relevant and ear
biscuit about why are you springing this
on me if you're gonna hit me with this
you should tell me ahead of time because
I mean well I'm looking back on the show
here I think the I think the solution
can be that when I talk about it I say
it's an ear biscuit when you talk about
it you say it's an ear biscuits and that
way we've got both covered you didn't
seem to imply that was your goal to just
a guava corner oh I've been going to
therapy for at least two years so I'm I
am able to arrive at equitable solutions
very quickly more quickly than someone
who's been in therapy for a couple of
months
we also have like this is an NPR show
you seriously brought that up just so
you could say that you've been to
therapy more than me
was that the whole point of the ear
biscuits ear biscuit it wasn't it was it
just hit me because I thought about it
yesterday I think you changed your mind
based on what I said no no you said we
got to do in your biscuits tomorrow I
was like I I'm gonna talk to him about
that on an air biscuit because that
would be funny yeah we do have a
correction that we need to make now what
has group of Fred's group of friends
that we went to NC State with that we
stay in touch with we've been video
chatting weekly a number of them I don't
know how many to probably listen to your
biscuits on the regular Greg I don't
know I think I don't know if Greg's
listens I know that harm lessons okay
Tim and doesn't listen and Tim listens
because he'll start texting us or now he
puts it in the thread he'll just start
commenting things to us conversationally
but he's referencing a conversation that
we've had on your biscuits and he's
apparently listening to it at that
moment and he's listening the day it
comes out most of the time I think
because it happens pretty you know he's
listening to the audio version which is
a correction right yeah he sent us a
text last night and it was Horace Grant
went to Clemson by the way oh so in the
previous episode were talking about the
last dance which interestingly we also
got into a little bit of a discussion
about Jordan because the whole the
classic conversation about how would
jordan be and modern whatever do you
like how I got into that conversation
and then made it about hip-hop music and
then harm and I ended up talking about
hip-hop and you guys couldn't talk about
Jordan anymore as soon as you texted
that I read half of it and then just
exited from the conversation
I had something else going on okay which
I'll tell you about it's that guy too
lots of things to talk about the yes I
was talking about the nature of NBA
basketball at the time and how the Bulls
were so unusual in that they had these
guys like you know the best player in
the world who didn't even make his
varsity team a sophomore year and then
guys who went to small schools and I
said Scottie Pippen and Horace Grant
what I meant to say was Scottie Pippen
and Dennis Rodman because Scottie Pippen
went to Central Arkansas and then Dennis
Rodman went to two different schools
North Central Texas and then
southeastern Oklahoma State these are
not typically your programs that are
feeders into the National Basketball
Association so click on the again libsyn
the great god one came from so we've
cleared that up but it did remind me you
know because Tim listens I mean I think
it was I think it was harm oh we're
about to get corrected again somebody
brought up in in our weekly scheduled
video conference that it was it was
weird having friends who have a podcast
where they talk about themselves and it
meaning us because I know if you're
following along I'm I'm talking about
them talking about us but he made the
point that it's weird to have
conversations with us about our personal
lives and then listen to an ear biscuit
and realize that we say ear biscuits you
keep an ear biscuits episode and
realizing that we had we had recorded a
show where we talked about the same
thing but then when we talked to them
about that aspect of our lives we didn't
tell them that we also made it a public
conversation that we had already had
that hadn't come out yet then after we
have the conversation with them they
hear it again when it goes out to all
the all of our audience and I was like
yeah I guess it I don't have any friends
who I get you know what I take
having friends have a podcast but I
don't really the personal nature of our
podcast I think it makes it a little
weird for a friend so sorry guys
now we're now we're talking about
talking about you and talking to you on
an episode that you don't know exists
we're going to talk to you soon
should we give you the heads up or just
let it slide no I let it slide I see it
as a little surprise speaking of
surprises the last piece of information
that we should cover before we get
started talking about therapy yeah
so as you know yesterday we went surfing
together that was fun was delightful i I
was started up paddling and I was
catching waves left and right or not and
I was trying to teach myself how to surf
on a regular board and me to say I'm
hurting today and I'm also very tired I
did get up one time as you saw it wasn't
pretty but I start for a little bit I
don't really want to talk about the
surfing
I'm just committed to getting better
because there's nothing to brag about so
you don't want to write but and also we
did see a guy out there who said big fan
yeah assume he was not talking about my
surfing ability no he and I'm a little
embarrassed that he saw me at all
to be honest but I'm embarrassed that he
saw you with me one of the things that
was happening yesterday it was raining
unexpectedly it was not in the forecast
it wasn't even on the weather when you
looked at the weather it was just
raining but it rained
where where where our homes are at and
also all the way across Los Angeles and
it was raining when we were surfing yeah
but one of the things that was happening
that is happening in my house as you
know is that we've got ongoing
construction on the outdoor area but
it's been on hold for many many weeks
during the crisis the pandemic but now
things are kind of getting somewhat back
to normal and the construction crew is
out there social distancing but working
but it's still an open pit basically of
just dirt and they had to drill a hole
in the side of my garage which you as
you know is below ground
to get power to run to something they're
doing out there they drill a hole in the
side of the foundation into the garage
and I think that they and I remember
seeing the hole in thinking okay well
we're gonna need to seal that hole but
of course I forgot about it apparently
they did as well so yesterday while we
were enjoying ourselves and surfing
water and not so much water but water
and mud we're pouring through that hole
into my garage and on top of that
dresser that I have in there this guy
dude it's basically all my stuff that I
can't fit anywhere else in the house
mostly like old electronics and like
cables that I don't know where they go
and stuff like that but also my old iMac
is sitting there and everything was
completely covered with mud and somehow
the way that it had cascaded into the
dresser it was an old IKEA dresser it
had filled the top drawers and then the
next layer and then the next layer it
had basically like put mud in all of it
all the drawers yes and then it went all
over the floor and went and settled in
the front of the garage a bit of a mess
and so last night I stayed up late you
cleaned it went through well they came
and cleaned up the mud Tudor cleaning up
the mud today and they're throwing out
that old IKEA furniture because once
IKEA furniture gets wet you can just I
mean first of all it's only good for
about 24 months to begin with but if it
gets wet no you can just arty lit up
like a crouton and you can put it on
your salad okay but so III had to go
through the stuff to tell the contractor
like what got ruined thankfully it's not
a whole lot of stuff there's some stuff
that I just bought some electronic stuff
that I just bought it needs to be
replaced but it wasn't like stuff that I
didn't have like you know backed up and
there's some old drives in there but it
was stuff that I've got backed up in the
cloud whatever
so anyway I'm that's why I was a little
bit late this morning because I like it
was tough to get moving because I stayed
up just wallowing in my own wetness and
mud Ness and sadness that sucks man
you know yeah how did that make you feel
that's something that therapists would
say right it's a how how did you process
this news well you know he would just
say the first thing how does that make
you feel and you just leave it and then
I would say something like well you know
it made me think about how this is
actually a really small thing I'm I'm
actually really really blessed
materially you know and I it's I can do
with a little inconvenience and he would
be like read read read read read don't
intellectualize it don't rationalize it
how does it make you feel so in other
words my tendency is to try to
immediately put the positive spin on it
that's my personality and he's like what
we can get there and it isn't what you
said is not untrue but you should
process how it makes you feel because
what tends to happen is what happened
this morning which is I was actually
very angry about it I called the
contractor and I and I'm just you know
I'm too nice
I was definitely as upset as I can get
at a contractor but still not really
that upset but he feels bad about it
but then like this morning when I was
trying to meditate I couldn't go down
there and meditate down there and do my
workout down there and so I was sitting
in the living room meditating and then
my family starts coming downstairs and
doing their stuff that they do in a
kitchen which i think is just eat and I
started getting mad started getting mad
while meditating and then Barbara wanted
to get out of their bedroom and she was
whimpering and I was like so what are
the Barbara and I'm sitting there the
meditating man
yes she's yelling at my family and it's
because I didn't stop and actually
process the way that the mud coming
through the hole made me feel oh I held
it in and then I released it on the
people who I care about most
would you next desk at work next Monday
oh so you didn't say you didn't talk
about it last night I did not know
because I do every two weeks okay all
right well let's get it into the therapy
stuff in a second but first we want to
remind you to head on over to mythical
dot-com where we have just a store of
stuff that is is going quick it's kind
of like mud coming in your garage it's
like you don't know you don't know when
it's gonna end and let me tell you
the muds gonna stop seeping soon cuz
there's lots of stuff I'm a list these
things off man
kind of under selling our merch by
saying mud we've got a lot of last
chance items that are the opposite of
mud and very limited quantity as I'm
saying this some of them are
disappearing so if any of this strikes
your fancy you better get over there
strike your fancy that's right we're
peak your fancy wreck your fancy poke
your fancy you don't poke your fancy
mythical merit badges we still got some
of those but not many gmm neon sign
joggers always curious tee one of my
favorite teas Sun wave long-sleeve tee
that's a good one says good mythical
morning insta growth tea for the ladies
know your worth coin pouch that's
running low the bark dance tea for the
ladies and the video club tea another
one of my favorites
get that thing now get all those now why
they last
ethical comm limited very lim
the for those of you watching you can
see that I I I'm now taken to my
mustache is getting kind of long I need
to cut it back but when I'm trying to
drink my drink here I'm having it then
like use a paper towel so it's really
annoying you have to dance all about
that guy that was the he was like the
owner of the Texas whatever the football
team Titans whatever they are and he had
a mustache that went completely over
both lips
lips covered come over both lips and
then just connected basically again with
his goatee that looked like another
mustache like it was like two dollops of
hair I don't understand that man yeah I
don't understand how that happens if
you're watching this you also see that
I'm wearing a t-shirt from the
thoughtful guy music video I still have
this t-shirt I workout in it sometimes
that's very sentimental you worked out
this morning I'm thinking about doing a
little a little activity after this cuz
know this is the first time I've put on
a shirt that has buttons there probably
a month let's get into therapy shall we
you know I can't remember how I
described the situation that led to me
deciding to go to therapy but it was a
long time coming and I'm distracted by
the leaf blower what yeah Chrissy's
trying to get me get me go therapy for
for our entire marriage she seems to be
saying well listen you can give me a
hard time right now because there's a
leaf blower right outside here and maybe
they won't hear you or the leaf blower
I can't remem I decision go to therapy
but yeah it was I knew I wanted to go it
was just kind of like the little things
keep you from doing it it's night well
you know cuz in the back here I decided
this is this is quite an undertaking all
that I'm gonna go to a professional and
talk about myself and this is something
that I was I believed in
I was never opposed to I was everyone
around me that I care about has a
positive experience with going to
therapy I mean in the discussions that
we've had in this venue and otherwise
I've been a very encouraged about your
experience and your level of growth and
like I've experienced the benefits of
that so it was there's nothing inside of
us
that was principally opposed to it in
any way matter of fact I would always
say I'm looking for a therapist but it
was kind of a lot it was like I intend
on looking for a therapist is what I
really should have said and I'm actually
having a hard time knowing what put me
over the edge do you remember what I
said that was like I'm actually gonna do
this it's on record but once I disarmed
once I decided yeah I don't remember
I don't recall but I I looked through
the I believe it's psychology comm
directory and found some people close to
me I also found it got recommendations I
asked you to ask your therapist for
recommendations because I don't want to
go to the same therapist as you that
didn't seem like the best idea you came
up dry but a couple other friends made
some suggestions one friend made a
suggestion and then I didn't like I
didn't like the sound of the therapist
name and I just did you know I just
didn't feel like I could say that name
like have a I don't know it was a
distraction to me I'm not gonna mention
what the name is well I will I will say
that's like a weird is it this is a that
right there is sort of an indication of
what will follow I think in terms of the
way that you approach this right and I
think that that's something that not
that you should have gone with that
person but I do think that the way that
you think about the things that you
embark upon is a particular way that I
think everyone will get into what makes
it made it difficult for me everyone has
like a difficult there's a difficult
threshold to cross well yeah it's like
all based and I think it was probably
just me putting up
barriers because maybe deep down I was
intimidated
what would the you know with the
prospect of getting into it you know I'm
I have had this growing sense that like
there's some sort of some sort of fear
with knowing that I'm just afraid of
what I might uncover and I feel like
maybe I'm like with my current coping
mechanisms in the way that I live my
life okay whatever it is that I'm not
fully exploring or coming to grips with
within my myself or my past or both that
I you know that I was I say I want to
get into it and I believe that it's a
good thing but I'm just I'm a little
afraid of what I'm afraid of
and the unknown of it and so that even
the the smallest reason could be reason
enough to not to not go for it which is
why I find it interesting they're like I
can't remember right now what the
trigger mechanism was but I think it was
just basically Chris I think part of it
was Christie saying would you keep
saying that you're looking for a
therapist but you're not actually and
you're not really taking any steps and
this can I no longer believe you it's
like she's kind of calling me on it and
it was true well we would have
conversations as well because we were we
were talking about therapy recommending
psychology calm talking about how
therapy was and then you would say
things like hey listen I'm a real
proponent of it I think the people in my
life have really benefitted from it but
after a while it's like okay well and
I've picked up in the second hand that
I'm probably good but I should go well
but so I so I finally found someone
whose name wasn't the other person name
wasn't Timmy but it was just like if
your therapist name is is like Tammy
it's just like it it's like that's just
a whit you know it's like I'm going to
I'm going to have a session with Timmy
you know it's like it's just weird you
know it's like it's like I'm gonna go to
get trained how to juggle by a clown or
something like that right yeah well that
would be more like I'm going to see my
therapist honkers well I could see Timmy
the clown I'm sure there's a Timmy the
clown out there that does birthday
parties it just you know it's I didn't
want to be distracted by not going to
see and Timmy's not the name but so I
found somebody else who had a much more
official sounding name and you know I
read about this guy he's like
information page on psychology comm and
then he said you can email him for just
for like a an initial consultation or
consultation may not have been a word
but okay it's kind of like an interview
both ways it's like let's just meet over
the phone let's have a 20-minute
conversation and see if my skills match
up with your what you're interested in
getting into so I set up that call and I
went to the I went down the street to
the my internet was out at this
particular time so which meant my phone
is very unreliable so then I had to
drive down and I'm sitting in the
parking lot of the grocery store where
my cell phone signals very strong so
that I can have a cohesive conversation
with this potential therapist and in the
20 minute conversation I made up my mind
that I was gonna be yeah I was gonna I
was gonna lay everything out there in
terms of like
this you know I instead of him it's only
20 minutes so I'm just gonna lay out
there everything that I want everything
I'm thinking about and I'm in his
concise of a way as possible and then
also hear his response and see if that's
something that resonates in terms you
know so I talked about
I talked about some of the fear stuff
that I think there's something there in
my past I talked about that a little bit
I talked about my I gave some statistics
on my on my upbringing and like being
from a broken home and like there being
something I gave like the bullet points
from a cast I talked about how my brain
works now I talked about how you know
there's a low level of anxiety that's
constantly there I put a lot of it out
there and I was I was I was comfortable
and prepared to do that and we had a
good conversation and you know I I and
he responded and said what his his
specialties were and there was a lot of
overlap there and but then he was like
but you gotta call me Timmy and you're
like okay got it talk to somebody else
well this guy and I'm not gonna give his
name but he has a first name he has a
last name and he also has a middle
initial in everybody in in his email
closing and that's what I call him
whenever I refer to him amongst my
family I call him Tim Dee Hammond's you
know that's not his name I made that up
off the top of my head if it didn't
sound like I'm gonna go into him again
I'm gonna go tim is fine Timmy not good
yeah yeah so I if my kids are like what
are you doing it's like well I've got
them I've got a therapy appointment with
Tim D Hammond's you know cuz it seems
official yeah I liked that too that the
guy I don't okay he has a man I have an
opinion I have an opinion about
referring to him by his full name every
time you talk to him a to your family
about him but okay you say so maybe
maybe I'm starting off on the wrong foot
so I I felt like we started off on the
right foot in this 20 minute
conversation there was a lot of overlap
I was very forthright he he was asking
questions I talked about my family
situation now talked about what was
healthy and what you know what I felt
like I wanted to explore and we set up
the first meeting and man I was I get
really nervous I don't know what it is
about
meanings I mean when we went surfing
yesterday I woke up nervous but I feel
like it's sometimes I misconstrued being
nervous or anxious with being excited
which is actually something that he said
in an early therapy appointment you know
I was I was talking about some situation
that I I wish I wasn't getting nervous
in and he was like well it sounds like
excitement but I wasn't but I do feel
like I was I was excited but I was
nervous to go in there and you know
you've you sitting in the waiting room
and then there's another person out
there on their phone so then when he
comes out he like looks at me and he he
doesn't say my name you know he just
gives me a nod because I guess he's
respecting any type of conversation that
I might have with somebody else they're
like if I were to say my name or
something like you know he wants to
respect my boundaries however strict
they may be so he comes out and he gives
me a nod and I follow him we haven't
even spoken and I was like I respect
that but it's still a little it puts me
on I'm on a edge right and I go in the
room and there's the couch there's an
actual couch now it's not a chaise
lounge it's not like a thing where it's
like well you don't lay down I could lay
down on this couch but it's not like a
chaise lounge you really can't do
anything but lay down right so that's
like the cartoon therapist forces in
every memory movie yeah every movie this
is like us us a reasonably sized
sectional but like my brains going about
a million miles an hour I'm like should
I lay down should I take off my shoes
should I should I you know it's like so
I sit there like a normal person on a
couch and we start a conversation he's
sitting in like a special a desk chair
that's borderline a recliner I mean I
guess if your job is is sitting and
listening you better have a good chair I
think it had a swivel to it these are
all the things I'm thinking in my first
appointment
I'm looking at what he's got on the wall
I'm looking at the bookshelf behind him
because as he's talking which isn't
often by the way I can look past him and
I can read some of the books that he's
been reading and learned something about
him how to do therapy for dummies yeah
if you see that if you see that behind
your guy your girl you need to do that I
don't know ask him to pull it off the
shelf and let's just read straight from
it okay so can I let me get in here you
know here it's kind of set you've set
you set the stage about like your first
impression and like what's going through
your mind when you walk in so and I'll
tell a little bit of my story now I do
want to just do a slight sidebar because
you know interestingly after we kind of
shared our loss to your story and for
those of you who didn't hear that that
was when we kind of talked about our
Christian background growing up working
as missionaries and then how we both
sort of changed the way that we think
and feel about all that and no longer
consider ourselves Christians obviously
going public with that was a little bit
of a lightning rod amongst the people
who listen to our podcast and just the
sort of the Christian media world in
some ways right and a lot of people
talked about it well one of the things
that I saw was a fair amount of
criticism about how you know of course
we get the criticism about how we've
gone all la but one of the things that
one of the things that comes along with
that is you guys have basically replaced
God with therapy right and in doing so
you've kind of replaced God with
yourself right because some people's
perspective on therapy is that it's so
self-absorbed and self focused and
people who go to therapy and are
constantly trying to figure out what
they feel and what they think and
process through these things can become
self-absorbed [ __ ] which i think is
kind of missing the point
but one of the things that Jesse and I
have talked about is that and as we said
in the last year's is we benefited in a
lot of ways from being a part of a
religious community right being a part
of a spiritual community there's a lot
of growth that took place in that
community and while we have our issues
with a lot of the views and some of the
foundational propositions of
Christianity at this point he was really
instrumental in us growing into the kind
of people that we are right absolutely
but one of the interesting things that I
sort of picked up on and this may not be
as much the case anymore it may have
been a little bit more like a 90s early
2000s kind of thing but in both me and
Jesse's experience there was very much a
one-size-fits-all sort of program for it
so it was basically like if you're a man
this is the kind of man that you should
be this is what being a man is about
right if you're a woman it's a very
different program this is what being a
woman isn't and I as a 40 year old man
had never ever dealt with a lot of stuff
that was going on inside my head in my
heart right because I knew how to fall
in line and I knew what the program for
me as a man was but which was based on
some things that I no longer agree with
but he just kind of struck me that when
I started going to therapy the the the
level with which I was actually dealing
with the specifics of my background my
family of origin and my personality was
kind of revolutionary and I'm not saying
that that doesn't happen in spiritual
communities and that doesn't happen in
the Christian community but it didn't
happen in the communities that I was a
part of right it really took taking that
next step in going into something where
I was gonna deal with myself in my own
[ __ ] right mm-hmm and I think that you
having seen me do that your wife did
that my wife too that
you knew that this wasn't gonna be like
going to a men's conference where it
might get really personal and it might
get really real but you're gonna kind of
walk away with some marching orders that
every other dude who's there is gonna
walk away with but you're probably not
gonna deal directly with some personal
growth or kind of directly addressing
some again this is probably happening in
some churches or whatever but it just
didn't happen for us right but I think
that you knew that like oh man I know
what this process is going to entail and
it's gonna entail getting in touch with
my past and for you that's is very
specific it's it's more of a typical
this person needs to be in therapy kind
of past right you know your dad left
raised by a single mom okay right okay
yeah you should be in therapy right now
for me somebody who came from a stable
home my parents are still together in my
mind
I had never in in the fact is is that
when it comes to like trauma yeah I
don't have a lot of try don't
everybody's got trauma everybody wants
to some people want to minimize I'm not
trying to minimize my own situation but
I don't have a pro this profile this is
like you need help right but it was my
wife seeing the way that I was
processing all the stuff all the
pressure that we had sort of put on top
of us over the years and the fact that
we're trying to lead this company and
pursue these dreams and it's just like
we were under a lot of pressure on a
really regular basis not to mention
compact that you started to go blind
yeah and it was coming out sideways both
in a way that I would kind of blow up
but also in the way that I was suffering
physically and the most acute symptoms
being the I don't even know what it's
called anymore but basically my retina
was I got some fluid behind my eye and
it's a stress-related condition
that can cause temporary blindness
pretty scary so you literally couldn't
see out of one eye well it could see was
very blurry like a center of the field
of vision yet so for me it was there's
these acute symptoms that kind of just
sent me over the edge but I just wanted
to cover that because yeah I you know
that little that that former self is
always sitting there on my shoulder kind
of telling me the way you sound right
now and I want it because I know that
people may be turned off by and I just I
want to and not to mention the fact that
there's a stigma associated with it
where it's like you've got to have
something specifically acutely wrong
you've got to have something in your
background that warrants it but you know
you don't have to have any this
condition to start working out right you
don't have to have a physical ailment in
order to begin working out well
exercising has been shown to make your
life better and longer in all kinds of
ways right and I think that in going to
the doctor on a regular basis is a good
idea and I think that you've everyone
has something in their personality that
has been constructed as a defense
mechanism based on their background and
the stuff that they've been through and
everybody's been through something and
so I just you know I think that anyone
is a candidate for it and can benefit
from it and I I believe that but I for
the longest time I didn't believe that
because I just I was never no one ever
said it but you know my entire
experience of growing up was in the
church
well my I want to limit this to my
specific experience and not talk about
the church in general my specific
experience and limited to that was I got
the impression by reading between the
lines that well as I cultivated my
relationship with God and that you know
Jesus can meet all of our needs and he
does that yes he does that through all
types of ways and through interactions
with people as included in
including professionals but I never I
did
I always thought of we taught about
counseling you might meet counsel you
might be couples counseling you might
need you know you might need some help
walking through this and it's in it's
very in in a spiritual environment but
therapy was something for people who had
a diagnosis
problem or something that was extremely
serious that then you got to go to
another level and I just thought that
like nothing in my life is bad enough
for that for therapy you know I can
handle everything with counseling and
through the cultivation of my
spirituality in in these other ways but
so I'm not present now I'm not presented
in either/or you can add you can
absolutely benefit from both at the same
time in the conversations that we've had
with our friends uh you know we've seen
that just to just to go back to Tim not
the fake name of my therapist but our
friend who knew that Horace Grant was
from Clemson who's a pastor now but so
moving on from that when I started
therapy I was I was ready to go in I was
ready to explore things matter of fact I
started to have ideas of what I wanted
to go into and so he would start off
with so how are you doing that how's
your date how's your week he is where he
would start and then I would be like
okay I have an idea of where I want to
go there's two different things I have
this immediate need of we're planning
this big vacation with my extended
family like Christy's side of the family
we're gonna go to Disneyworld
like I but like I'm feeling out of
anxiety associated with that and I want
to deal with that in a healthy way and I
don't want to be the one to screw that
up for the my entire extended family
because this is a big deal but and
that's the only like an immediate need
but then I got this the deeper stuff
that I know I want to get into about
like my past
and how I view myself and how I how
there's so much like my inner critic is
so strong and I feel like I suffer from
that and so in in the first two sessions
I talked about both of those two things
interestingly enough we were going
through having put out the last year's
podcasts and I chose not to bring any of
that up because it was like that's a
whole other thing I'm not ready to get
into even though it was something that
was very much dealing with it the time
you know said in like he didn't even
really have an inkling that that was
going on because I never brought it up
because in my mind I had prioritize
these other things I wanted to talk
about and get into and then so even once
I started to get into those things I
half my mind is trying to figure out how
does this work and how does he work
specifically and how do I work so it
wasn't just having a conversation but it
was analyzing everything to figure out
the system you know so I would be like
okay he'll he'll he asked me a general
question and then I dictate what I want
to talk about and then if I make a
statement he'll it if I get to a point
where I'm done talking then he'll ask
another clarifying question about it and
I'll need to think about it for a second
and answer and then when I'm done with
that and just let me finish what I
observed as a system and then at that
point I would observe sometimes I would
finish talking and he wouldn't ask
anything he wouldn't say anything he
would just be quiet and that's when it
got a little weird because I'm
immediately feeling like okay I'm done I
put something out there he's quiet
am I supposed to talk now are you
supposed to talk it's like that scene in
that scene in Star Wars but he's like uh
are you gonna talk now or am I gonna
talk you know and so I brought so much
my brain was so hot and going into this
situation and I
then that's how it went for the first
few he was like two different levels of
conversation going on in my own mind
yeah so I mean we talked about this a
little bit but you're a ninny a grim one
you don't have to know what the AMIA
grim is and we haven't done an episode
about it yet but you're you're a
perfectionist right so you're driving
sort of guiding principle in life is you
want to make sure that you're doing
things right for me the best possible
way which is a performer so I want to
make sure that I'm doing things not
necessarily right but I want to be the
best at whatever it is right I want to
perform and those are actually pretty
similar and they manifest themselves in
pretty similar ways especially when you
encounter anyone else in life right and
so me and you tend to be super
self-aware and we analyze everything and
we're thinking about things almost like
a filmmaker you know stepping back and
observing the way things that are
happening and what what that's doing is
it's again this is really just a
figurative way of talking about it but
you're kind of getting out of your heart
and getting out of your feelings and
you're getting into your head and you're
moving into this analytical place where
there's not a lot of progress there's
not a lot actual work that happens once
you step out and you get it especially
when it gets so analytical that you're
actually thinking only about the process
that's happening between you and that
person but it's the only natural
response for most people like for me the
thing that took me forever and I still
have a tendency to do this because I'm a
performer sometimes my favorite be a
point that will come up and I'm like oh
man I I don't have anything for him
today you know I don't have anything for
him today right like I'm not it isn't
going to be worth his time to spend time
with me today because I'm not gonna
bring it you know I've got to perform
for this guy and and what and that may
take the form of very early on and like
some of the initial things it was
alright I kind of want to let this guy
know that in again this wasn't a
conscious process but it was like
I kind of want to let this guy know that
I'm not crazy okay it's like all right
let's just get let's get that in a way
I'm not I'm not crazy you know I'm a
stable person I'm a stable genius and I
you know I kind of understand what's
happening here I know what you're trying
to do and I and and I am basically
saying hey I'm gonna be a good partner
in this like I I'm gonna give you what
you need which is you just tell me how
I'm supposed to go about this and I'll
do a good job at it like you know show
me the steps to perform because as soon
as I understand that I'll lock in and
I'll be your best patient ever again not
a conscious process but that's how I
find myself whenever if like I'm
wracking my brain to figure out what it
is I want to talk about before I go in
there and I don't feel good I feel
horrible
until I can answer that question and
just to skip ahead a little bit like we
had we went from week to week cuz it was
a trial thing and it was I said let's do
every week and then with with the
pandemic and the isolation things were
in flux and we didn't schedule and then
it was like let's just do every other
week and then it got to a point where I
was like ironically I was having the
most difficult time you know that as you
know this past this past week has been
extremely difficult this is you know
when I did the livestream with Britt and
I shared some of this they are too
because you know with what Chrissy's
going through and her level of anxiety
and me caring for her and it's been very
difficult for both of us and you know
we've talked about all this but
ironically I made an active decision not
to schedule a therapy appointment
because I just felt like I don't even
know the reason it was like now that I'm
really into this thing and we had talked
about it when it wasn't when it wasn't
as a cute I had had a meaning or two
with him remotely
and I had we we had discussed it because
I had made up my mind I wanted to
discuss it and then I found myself
canceling the appointment and I haven't
gone or we haven't met in a couple of
weeks and now there is no standing
appointment at all I found it so
interesting how when I'm going through
the toughest time I made a decision in
spite of myself to not go at all it's
like and I well here's here's here's the
ironic thing right the ironic thing is
that you're so concerned about doing it
wrong that you know what you're actually
doing it wrong yeah yeah because because
it's like again I I think that it's
again is it comes from a slightly
different place but the application is
often the same and that is I've stopped
is the thing I have stopped doing and
this would be my advice for you is I've
stopped thinking about the appointment
before the appointment is happening
I've stopped thinking about well what am
I gonna bring tonight like what is my
border my bullet points this isn't like
sixth grade when I was calling my
girlfriend and I had to have a list of
things to talk about so I wouldn't run
out right this is about getting in touch
with what I'm feeling and ironically as
well you know when you talk about what
you're going through which we've
obviously been talking a lot about what
you've been going through I'm going with
going through what Christie in my last
appointment and again I've kind of made
this habit of like I'm not gonna think
about this I'm just going to I'm not
going in with an agenda even though it
is up to me right he's gonna say how you
doing so he said he was like how you
doing or not was like I don't know I
think I mean I think I'm doing okay and
then I'll just kind of just start
talking about things that are going on
and you know the thing that he's really
good at is picking up on super
empathetic and
can kind of get to things that I don't
even know that I'm feeling
but basically what our appointment
became our conversation became about was
the fact that I was having a lot of
anxiety about what was happening with
you and Christy like that we were
talking about it and I'm trying to
figure out what can i what can I do
about this right like what can I say
what can I say to help you and Christian
during this time Jesse and I are talking
about it a lot and it's like I started
realizing that I was having all this
anxiety about your situation but if I
had I just thought about my agenda I
would have never got there what what I
would have done is I would have come I
would have I would have gone in and I
would have thought well the thing that I
need to talk about right now is this
issue that I'm having it work or
whatever but when I go in without an
agenda and I really just try to just
start talking about whatever it is it
might be happening even sometimes it's
just like catching up with a friend
right because where I'm for it we're
friends now so it might just be like oh
we did something cool we went surfing
today I surf with the dolphin or
whatever it might be and then that will
lead into something else but I that
would be that's been the most helpful
thing for me is getting past the agenda
and the planning or the prioritizing
thinking that you've got to put this
ahead of this I got to deal with this
before I get to this it's not organizing
a garage right and that's your Tennessee
is gonna be I got to approach this the
way I would approach washing dishes
well letting you and you know I would
say I appreciate that well let me let me
let me just respond all that because
there's a lot in there I think first of
all it's very touching for me to hear
that you talked about my situation in
your therapy and I feel like that means
a lot to me and I think you know I
I feel like I reap the benefits of that
in terms of the conversations that we've
had with the you know at this point the
the light at the end of the tunnel is is
very bright like I'm you know Christy's
in a in a very good place and I'm in a
very good place but when it was at the
darkest moments and we were having those
conversations it was it was extreme it
wasn't done without it so I want to
thank you for that and I also want to
thank the other friends like the friends
that we talked about at the top of this
episode you know every week having that
touch point where it's like we can just
hang out and like we're asking how
everybody's doing and that's been
extremely helpful and I've I've told him
that but I just you know for those of
them that are listening I would I want
to thank them specifically now because
it was extremely helpful and I I'm
seeing that if I would have just gotten
out of my own way I could have also
benefited from having having am i
standing therapy appointment that if I
would have made it standing and not just
made it a question mark every time so
yeah I so then but you know sitting back
to this conversation
I just feel like that's very helpful and
it's interesting because in the
conversations that I have with him at a
certain point I'm like okay this is an
hour I'm at the 45 minute mark and I
feel like I've talked about I've gotten
I've gotten my marching orders and I
will uh myself saying things like I've
said this on a number of sessions about
45 minutes in I'll be like I've got a
practical plan that addresses my concern
a complaint that that I decided to bring
up as part of my curriculum right and
what I'll say is I'll say
that's helpful so it's like it's
basically me saying I got what I came
for
I got my money's worth you know or what
however I'm thinking about I would say
yeah that's very helpful and then but
then I would feel like okay but it's
also an assignment because now I need to
apply this plan so that next time we
talk in a weaker - whenever the standing
appointment is that I got a show that
I've applied this like is there's a as
if there was a test I'm realizing that
you know I because at one point we
talked about like doing some work where
we were talking about the inner critic
and he said you know what a creative
exercise you can do is you can start to
create a character profile for this
voice of an inner critic in your mind
you know you might you might see him as
you run a you run a company that is your
life and your inner critic is is the
head of security and he might say his
name is Bob and Bob comes up to you and
he's very zealous and he's like well you
know we've got to put armed guards at
every door of the facility and then
you're like Bob I I appreciate the
sentiment but we're not gonna put armed
guards at every door but what we are
gonna do is this and you put Bob in his
place and you because he's just your
head of security he's not he's not
running your company but he's like you
can come up with any way you want
and so I was like oh man now I just got
a homework assignment and I'm talking to
Christy and Lilly about this ever I'm
like and now it is here it is I it's
been a week and I'm talking to him in
another week I'm halfway there and I
haven't I haven't I was gonna journal
down my character description of what my
inner critic looked like I was like and
I asked Christy and Lilly I was like is
this what you mean by doing the work
because this is like literal homework
and now that I have gone I'm over
halfway there and I haven't done my
assignment I'm like now I'm I'm
I'm all up in arms about that and then
we did have a session and I was able to
talk about how about my inner critic and
things that I but I kind of crammed to
do this homework and like it kind of
rubbed me the wrong way
yeah well I mean I haven't had it and
this may be my therapist insight into me
as a performer I haven't really had any
specific assignments he has suggested a
couple of things that might be like you
know I think he would be helpful to
write that down or you know and but what
the the thing that I've kind of gotten
into the habit of is you know we kind of
go through at the end we kind of go
through he's always says what stands out
for you tonight you know and that's sort
of that that's my cue to figure out what
the big the big takeaways are and then I
went for a long time having these like
really in what I consider to be
significant insights and then I would
sort of just remember them again next
time and in now if there's a significant
insight I do try to like okay take ten
minutes you know in journal about it
just just to kind of remember it to kind
of put a stake in the ground but yeah I
think that and so you have to since that
assignment you had you you have been
back yeah I went back once and he didn't
grill me on it I told him I did do it
and I did benefit from it and like but
did you talk about did you talk about
the way that you thought about the
assignment no and and the thing that
Christy and Lily told me as I like told
them about how I were approaching it
they say things like he's there for you
you you seem to be talking like you're
there for him
and right which is kind of what we're
saying and they said you should just you
should talk to him about that and I was
like okay that's that's that well it's
funny because when it was like yeah
you're giving me an assignment so my
therapist and I have talked about you
and and you'd go into therapy
right we've taught I talking about
everything so and in talking with him
about your initial reservations that
you've explained to me that got us
talking about the way that it got us
talking about the way that we talked
about we talked to each other and the
way that I perceive it
mm-hm and that hope the way that I
perceive it as a performance and I've
told him I was like sometimes you know
for the longest time I was like what do
I have for him yeah and so that that
became like getting to that level of
specificity and laying it all out there
and what you started realizing is that
you just got all these little things
that you're hiding not only from your
therapist for from yourself yourself
yeah and it's just like you you're
playing this little game of like hide
the ball and you got to just take you
got to take the cuffs off the balls man
you got to put your boss on the tape but
I mean I'm I'm adjusting how I'm looking
at it because I realized in the number
of ways that I'm looking at it wrong and
I'd you know I do realize going back to
how we perceive therapy I think the
thing that I'm bringing to it is you
know the only point of reference that I
have directly is counseling and
accountability groups now in in in our
church youth group and definitely in
college we would set up these
accountability groups where it's like
hey you you you have a small group maybe
it's just one other person that that you
trust and that you want to share things
that you want you want to improve in
your life it can be spiritual in nature
they could be practical in nature but
you've got someone who will hold you
accountable when you get together the
the the main point of the meeting is for
them to ask you because you've given
them permission it's kind of like a
personal trainer especially in these
times where you're not with the person
was training they're like have you done
your exercises this week well it could
be that for anything it could be like
this did you meet this goal of that
guard did you not participate in this
activity that you promised you weren't
gonna do kind of thing any man in most
accountability the most accountability
groups between men it would be did you
look at porn this week and they all in
the ultimate the ultimate accountability
hack this is the thing that I never
really understood until later and I
think a lot of people were operating
under this principle the ultimate
accountability hack is just lying never
lied you'd like accountability no no no
I'm saying that I know I didn't lie but
I figured out later that some of the
people they were having they were
hacking the system they were lying
they were hack the lumber I've never
actually heard that is a euphemism but I
think you wanna think it I think it's
whack the lumber okay well to be
specific I feel like and then when you
go to counseling if you have a problem
and you're like you like when I would
meet one my pastor you'd be like I'm
dealing with this it was it was a
positive experience but I think in my
mind there was a negative aspect to it
that I now apply to therapy and that is
I always assumed there was a judgement
you know it's like it's like going to
confession
it's like going to confession if you're
Catholic which we never were but yeah so
it's like hey I'm I'm sharing this and
in the response that you get from the
authority figure is well this is the
this is the proper this is the proper
belief or action or and this is how
you're falling short but you know what
here's here's the strength and here's
the path to get back on the right track
but but there's an implied judgment
there right that the thing with therapy
that I just can't seem to let sink in is
that it's a judgment-free zone there's
been plenty of things that I put out
even on that first 20 minute phone call
you know he asked me some pointed
questions about how do I deal with
stress and stuff like that and how I
deal with the the things that I was
confessing I felt like I approached it
like a confessional and I just felt like
I've I confessed more things that like
and then would cringe it's like yeah
this is expecting expecting there to be
some implied unspoken judgement that
then led to so this is what you do to
correct that yeah but that's I don't
that's not what therapy is therapy's not
know but what we're looking for our
marching orders I mean and but but
there's a but also a judgment I think
anticipating a judgment and then a
correction which the correction is the
marching orders and so it's there's a
pageant that's very I think it's very
related to I think it's probably pretty
typical but I think it's it was
reinforced by our background because it
when you when you went to talk to
someone who was in some sort of
spiritual authority over you you that's
what you were looking for you were
looking for correction what what is the
authoritative thing that I'm supposed to
submit to and do right now and and then
with that there's some personalities
that just lock onto that like for
somebody who is a perfectionist you lock
on to the instructions for someone who
is a performer we lock on to the
instructions as well because it fulfills
that need and I think the thing that's
been so difficult is you start realizing
that
so many of your issues kind of relate to
that orienting principle in life the
thing that you the way that you approach
everything right which is why the India
gram is very helpful because it helps
you understand that sort of main driver
and then you start realizing that
everything that I do the way that I have
behave in my relationships the way that
I behaved in my job and the things that
I'm trying to do long-term they're all
being filtered through that and so when
you're therapy because it's inevitable
because it's another relationship right
it's just another relationship with
another thing that you do your tenancy
is always going to be to approach it in
exactly the same way I mean I'm not
saying I I fixed this the only thing
that I've done is it hit me real hard
that oh you're just applying the same
old Rett approach to this as well you
you've put the red spin on this
relationship and and but but this is the
whole idea this relationship is to break
that down and you know and I think that
you're so early in the process right now
that you applying that pressure to
yourself is actually keeping you from
getting into the process and having the
appointment you know yeah I don't think
I just it's like my my entire being just
can't believe that he's he's there to
help me explore and gain insight into
myself without judgment like I I haven't
gotten there yet
so I don't know if that's it's probably
something to talk about you know but
again I don't I'm gonna send it I'm
gonna send an email and say hey let's
get back on track you know the these and
and kind of give him some of the
background or maybe I'll talk about that
a lot of this stuff I think I'll talk
about and the next time I talk to him
and then set the groundwork for hey I do
want to make this sustaining appointment
I don't want there to be a question mark
week to week where I have to make an
active decision and can just bow out of
this thing and then just talk about some
of these issues with him and like half
insights that I've gotten you know see
how he see how he responds to that but
you know it's because like you said it
is a relationship with a person and it's
but it's a it's a professional
relationship that then you know like I I
just I need I need therapy to reorient
my my my expectations my my approach how
I do this thing but again am I now am i
falling back into the trap even as I
talk but like okay constantly I haven't
been doing it right I'm gonna talk to
know about how I do it right oh good
it's the it's the I'm doing right now
it's it's one of the reasons that and we
should we should definitely talk about
do at least an episode on meditation
because I think that the thing that
mindfulness meditation or just a simple
like focusing on the breath meditation
does is it reveals sort of the pattern
and nature of your thoughts and for me
and I assume this is the case for many
people and probably also for you like
for me the mitts
I can't I'm such a three I'm such a
performer that I cannot sit down and
meditate without picturing someone
watching me meditate like I'm always
doing something for an audience right
and then in the moment that I have an
insight while meditating I'm thinking
about the conversation that I'm going to
have in the future with someone to tell
them about this insight so that they
will think better of me but here's the
thing meditation brings these things out
in their ugliness and shows them to me
it shows that pattern it's like you
start realizing that oh you're cut
you're getting into that thing again
where you can't just be in the present
you're thinking about the past you're
thinking about the future you're
applying these principles and then in
every single thing that you do like for
me like I sit this constantly like I'm
gonna have to be resistant to not talk
to my therapist about this ear biscuit
in a way that pays like hey you know
those conversations that link and I have
had about therapy or whatever like
talking about it in a way that positions
me as the as the protagonist right as
the star like that's my issue and so I
just have to constantly it but at least
I'm thinking about it right at least
there's a there's an awareness but for
the longest time it was just like my way
of being and I didn't even understand
the destructive nature of it does that
make sense yeah yeah so yeah you're
gonna like the way that you think about
the one about it the way that you think
about the way that you think about it
mm-hm
will be subject to the way that you
think about and you got to think about
that man alright that was funny I guess
it may be it's also true it's true okay
yes
again I don't in conclusion I have no
conclusion for anyone else so as with as
with all err biscuits to take from it
take from it what you won't take nothing
from it but I appreciate the
conversation and again it's as hell it's
helpful for me and that's plenty that's
plenty
yes well I guess I'll give a wreck now
yeah so it is your turn to give a wreck
go for it thank you to whoever shared
this video with me and actually several
of you shared this video there was a
video by a guy at youtuber named Bo
miles who is an Australian University
professor and sort of adventurer who has
a YouTube channel that he doesn't upload
very often but because mostly because
the videos that he makes take a lot of
effort the very artistic vlogs and vlog
is probably not the best word but he did
a video called the human beam where he
ate his bodyweight in beans canned beans
and it took him 40 days God I mean yeah
he documents his process in a very he's
a funny guy he's funny but he's also
very introspective and thoughtful and it
was just I got into his YouTube channel
and you know he took a trip he kayaks
from Australia to Tasmania and made like
a six part series just some very special
YouTube content that isn't it's not at
all really trying to play a play the
game to get clicks it's just like this
dudes just live in a life down there in
Australia and has found a really
compelling way to capture it and it's
been you got me to watch it and it's
been a source of inspiration for us yeah
creatively so I agree with that ro Bo
miles and that's boast but like be EA
you beautiful Bo miles that's a good
name I'm not saying it's beautiful but
this is how you spell in therapy alright
hashtag ear biscuits will let you will
speak at you next week
I just lost Rhett because my my iPad
died I don't know if he's still talking
to you
but I'm gonna choose to shut down this
episode so at least we have that from
one of us very interested in what
redstone right now but I have lost
contact with him at the perfect moment
hashtag your biscuits we'll talk at you
next week
thanks for all the love and support that
you've given to me and Christy and it
means a lot to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]